and welcome to hannity we begin tonight
with the fox news alert as we speak your
president joe biden is headed to the
beach in delaware yet again for another
long weekend away from the white house
uh according to the washington examiner
he has already spent 188 days on
vacation including 130 days in delaware
52 at his presidential retreat camp
david six days in beautiful nantucket
and is steadfastly refusing to release
visitor logs from most of these
locations joe is now on pace to spend
what would be a whopping
553 days away from the white house in
his first and probably only term now
that's more than any other president in
the modern era this is as millions of
americans are now suffering from a dire
baby formula shortage an ongoing supply
chain crisis looming stagflation
pending recession all 50 states have now
hit record high gas prices and the
nationwide average is nearing five
dollars a gallon and by the way good
luck getting diesel below eight bucks a
gallon now 25 percent of americans are
now delaying retirement because of joe's
inflation two-thirds of americans are
now living paycheck to paycheck two out
of every three americans you think
things are bad now buckle up because the
fed is now poised to raise interest
rates yet again this time a full point
which will cause property values most
people's biggest investment to plummet
and send this country straight into a
deep recession if you are on a fixed
income if you're in the poor middle
class they're all suffering miserably
because of biden's new green deal
socialism and of course his adherence to
the democrat and the democratic party
climate alarmism religious cult it's
like you can't even de-program these
people they're so nuts yet joe biden is
headed to the beach yet again but not
before lecturing ordinary tax paying
hard-working law-abiding american
citizens and threatening to rip away our
second amendment rights which he
believes is not absolute i tend to
disagree take a look
the second amendment like all other
rights is not absolute
we need to ban assault weapons in
high-capacity magazines
and if we can't ban assault weapons then
we should raise the aids to purchase
them from 18 to 21.
strengthen background checks
enact safe storage law and red flag laws
repeal the immunity that protects gun
manufacturers from liability
address the mental health crisis
deep into the trauma
of gun violence and as a consequence of
that violence
enough
enough
but my god
the fact that the majority of the senate
republicans
don't want any of these proposals even
to be debated
or come up for a vote
i find unconscious
meet the moment let us finally do
something
now we'd like to use joe's favorite
language for god's sakes joe do
something
for god's sakes joe i have a question
why didn't you and barack obama do
something in eight years to stop the
violence in the city of chicago obama's
hometown why not joe and for god's sake
joe why did you never one time not one
time as vp for eight years mentioned a
single child's name killed in obama's
hometown when you were vice president
for god's sakes why you never lifted a
finger joe why you know save us the
lectures because you've been missing in
action for all of these years now this
divisive speech tonight was nothing more
than a political stunt pretty
predictable likewise the democratic
party and the new contr gun control bill
that too is a political stunt in an
election year it will not pass the
senate that didn't stop one far-left
member of congress from openly
fantasizing about his party's wildest
dreams take a look
enough of your thoughts and prayers
enough
enough
you will not stop us from advancing the
protecting our kids act today
you will not stop us from passing it in
the house next week and you will not
stop us there
if the filibuster obstructs us
we will abolish it
if the supreme court objects we will
expand it and we will not rest until we
have taken weapons of war out of
circulation in our communities
each and every day we will do whatever
it takes to end gun violence whatever it
takes oh that means full
authoritarianism that sounds great in
case you haven't noticed democrats they
don't like to they don't like our system
of checks and balances our constitution
something called the bill of rights they
just want one party rule in perpetuity
forever and ever and ever and that's why
they want the court packing they want
d.c statehood they want to end the
filibuster
and they don't want voter id laws the
president himself wants to disarm lawful
americans because he thinks the second
amendment is about hunting dear and not
an absolute right joe biden well has to
be one of the dumbest people in d.c and
that is saying a lot
so dumb that joe can't even figure out
why his poll numbers are cratering right
now he's underwater look at this in 40
out of 50 states a new reuters poll has
them at a whopping 36 percent approval
rating according to nbc news he is
absolutely mystified totally bewildered
about these plummeting numbers he thinks
it might be a messaging problem and he's
now blaming his own staff and pointing
fingers at them
of course it's not a messaging problem
it's a reality problem right now every
american is struggling to get by
two-thirds living paycheck to paycheck
and by the way they are reminded every
time they fill up their tank because
they're paying double what they paid
under president trump and then they go
to the grocery store in any other store
and they're paying almost double for
everything they buy in every store they
go to unless they need baby formula then
they have to drive from store to store
to store in order to locate a single
carton which is probably locked behind a
window because of rampant shoplifting
then these americans return home with a
mortgage that is underwater and an
electric bill that is higher than ever
then they turn on the tv to see their
retirement funds are plummeting a crisis
at our southern border they see violent
crime and epidemic in almost every major
american city oh cities that have been
run by liberal democrats for decades and
states that have been run by liberal
democrats for decades the states that
like defunding dismantling the police
the states that like no bail laws
so what we have is an old decrepit
president who can barely shuffle his
feet can't read a teleprompter prefers a
phony oval office to the real oval
office and everywhere americans are
looking they are faced with the reality
every single day of the consequences of
all of joe biden's policies and the
failures of those policies they see a
president who will soon be headed to
saudi arabia what to beg them for more
oil instead of producing that oil right
here at home that's joe's plan to bring
down gas prices that's it he's offering
no other solutions oh unless you
consider doing a deal with the mueller's
in iran that want us dead or the
murdering thug dictator in venezuela
unless you consider that a solution take
a look
but the idea we're going to be able to
you know click a switch
bring down the cost of gasoline
is not likely in the near term nor is it
with regard to food just like jimmy
carter
just put on a sweater and lower your
thermostat not only is joe short on
solutions but he also refuses as per
usual to take any responsibility for
anything not even the inflation that he
himself caused his policies caused his
economic policies and his energy
policies cost take a look what are you
guys going to admit that you were wrong
about inflation
no easy questions today huh the treasury
secretary says that she was wrong so why
doesn't everybody here at the white
house okay so look what uh what the
secretary was pointing out uh out this
is talking about yesterday when she was
doing her her hit uh with her tv hit
with cnn is that there have been shocks
to the economy that have exacerbated
inflationary pressures which couldn't
have been foreseen 18 months ago
let me
i'm trying to answer your question
hold on i was just getting to the why
not uh including russia's decision to
invade ukraine multiple successive
variants of covid and lockdowns in china
just pathetic now according to joe's own
administration joe biden can do no wrong
and now based on tonight's speech the
president is deeply concerned about gun
control and yet he can't even be
bothered to stick around in the d.c
swamp this weekend and broke her deal on
capitol hill take a look at this
if the president thinks that congress
must act immediately to end this
epidemic of gun violence is he going to
bring any of the key players from
capitol hill to the beach with him
tonight
oh okay um uh so
i don't have a big part of candidate
fighting's whole
thing that he knows how to get things
done he does he does i'm asking why it
is that you can say he wants to give
these negotiations you want to go to the
beach with the president tonight is that
what you're trying to tell me
on that the weather it is pouring
outside like cats and dogs it is not
great
but look if you know are dying every day
why would this president then say he
wants to give it some space and let
somebody else but you're also going to
hear you're going to hear from the
president
tonight it's so urgent he's not sticking
around because all of this is political
theater that's why he never mentioned
the murders that took place under his
watch and obama's watch in obama's home
city of chicago it's all theater it's
another shameless attempt to vilify
political opponents and it's again
feigned moral outrage because otherwise
you'd be consistent you would have
spoken out in 2009 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 you know you would have spoken out he
didn't
joe once promised to bring yes the
country together and unify the country
that was a lie he promised to take
responsibility for his actions not blame
others that too was a big lie he
promised to shut down the virus restore
the soul of our nation well we had a
hundred thousand new cases of cova today
that was a lie he promised not to
abandon americans in afghanistan yeah
tony blinken even admitted what two
weeks ago yeah we left them behind
another lie he promised that inflation
was transitory turns out it looks like
it's almost permanent that was another
lie he promised gas prices would come
down another lie so joe if you really
want to know why your poll numbers are
so low you know stop being so mystified
and shocked and wondering and pondering
the great mysteries of the earth here
it's not complicated you're not doing
anything right you're not helping the
american people and all you seem to care
about is getting away from dc and going
to sleep and taking your naps on the
beach
america doesn't trust him because he has
been so honest more importantly they
don't respect him because his policies
are a disaster they don't you know
revere him because they know the family
is corrupt they don't believe in him
because they can't afford to and they
don't like him because he blames
everything on some everybody else
including his own staff as the new york
post michael goodwin put it the u.s
loves a winner not a whiner joe biden is
a whiner in chief hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else